هذا مكتب الطيران الاسرائيلي في مطار شار
دغول في الطابور فرنسيون واسرائيلي مزدوج
الجنسيه حجزوا في اخر لحظه لكن تعليمات
اعطيت بمنحهم اولويه للسفر انهم من الذين
لبوا نداء اسرائيل بالمشاركه في الحرب على
غزه وسائل الاعلام الفرنسيه رافقتهم في
رحتهم الى
تيبرا
وبدات تغطيتها مشوبه بتمجيد اختيار هؤلاء
المتطوعين لقد اصبح حضورهم في الجيش
الاسرائيلي
حقيقه هذا البرلماني هو الذي اثر ضجه في
فرنسا بمطالبته بالتحقيق بشان الفرنسيين
الذين ذهبوا للقتال في صفوف جيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي
ومحاكمتهم لا اقبل ابدا كبرلمان ان يرتكب
فرنسيون جرائم حرب بجانب الجيش الاسرائيلي
في غزه لست هنا في وارد الحكم على الناس
لكنني اطلب فتح تحقيق واذا ثبتت التهم
فعلى العداله
محاكمتهم نشر بعض الفرنسيين المنخرطين في
صفوف جيش الاحتلال مقاطع فيديو يفتخرون
فيها بوجودهم في ساحه
الحرب فارتفعت اصوات اخرى تطال ب مساءلتهم
وتجدد تحذيراتها من خطوره السماح بالقتال
مع الجيش
الاسرائيلي نبهنا منذ مده الى خطوره
الاتفاقيه بين فرنسا واسرائيل التي تسمح
للفرنسيين بالخدمه في جيش احتلال اجنبي
نحن البلد الوحيد في العالم الذي يسمح
بهذا الامر تذهب الى هناك تقول انك يهودي
تريد الخدمه في الجيش الاسرائيلي وبعد ذلك
تعود الى فرنسا
ولا تتعرض للمسائله لكن لو ذهب فرنسي
للقتال في سوريا وعاد فسيرى ما الذي سيحدث
له ورغم ما احدثته الضجه من تفاعلات وسط
بعض الفئات الشعبيه والسياسيه لا تزال
الحكومه ترفض الخوض في الموضوع صمت لم
يفاجئ بعض
المتابعين الحكومه الفرنسيه لا تريد الخوض
في هذا الموضوع فهي تبدو من خلال سياساتها
وكانها تزكي سياسه الجيش الاسرائيلي
والجنود الفرنسيين الذين يقاتلون هناك دون
تقدير انعكاسات ذلك مثلا ان يكون لدينا
بعد انتهاء الحرب جنود فرنسيون في الاحياء
السكنيه شاركوا في مجازره بغزه الطريقه
العلنيه التي التحق بها رعايا فرنسيون
بالجيش الاسرائيلي اثرت تساؤلات كثيره
بينها سؤال كبير كيف يمكن لهم ان يعودوا
الى فرنسا وكانه لم يحدث شيء نور الدين
بوزيان الجزيره باريس